what's in the box so is it your fragile
ego that's my you stole my joke you
stole my joke that was the joke I made
at you before we recorded you stole my
joke no it did I I write all your
material you
hack so as you know I have a lot of
beautiful stuff in my house because I
think it's something very important
everyone listening if you accomplish
something that is great some
achievement what I like to do is buy
myself something to remember that moment
because sometimes when it's hard you
forget you've done great things in your
life you've had accomplishments doesn't
have to be some amazing Factory it could
just be like my first job or I got a
raise or you know what I
I
anything
so there's this amazing sculptor named
Jake Michael singer singer who's a
sculptor and I saw a piece of his how's
his singing
voice this is joke's not I hold on I
could go somewhere with this how's his
singing voice do you want me to write
your joke for you yeah what's the
punchline um
hard there it is that's that's what she
said so I followed him on Instagram he
followed me back
MH and he's like if I made he say what's
the point of being an
artist if this work I create isn't in
the spaces of people I like and admire
he's a big fan of yours you've given him
an our episodes together give him Joy so
he said if I get a SC make Lex a
sculpture will he put on the shelf
behind him and what that reminded me of
is when I was a kid uh you read Batman
comics and there's the Batcave and the
Batcave has all this cool stuff in it I
didn't realize until much later that all
of those things in the Batcave had an
origin story so the giant Penny the
dinosaur there was actually a story
where that came from so if you're a fan
of a show you can spot oh this is when
this appeared this is when that appeared
this is when that appeared so he made
you this
sculpture uh he lives in Turkey um and
it's called chance murmur and it is I
haven't even seen it yet it is
absolutely beautiful all this so you
want to do a little unboxing yes okay uh
axe
or body
spray all right let do let
unbox I'm so
excited he Li ins out the
box you know uh that Steven Seagal movie
where there's like a stripper that comes
out of the box is that uh under SI he's
on a
boat you're not an action film guy
no
one what does the pirate say when he
turns
80 what i
m I'm M
oh oh see that's how I know you don't
like humor I just don't like Pirates
well your mom does do you play any
musical instruments
no no Nei do you I've seen your guitar
videos
okay here's a big piece of wood for you
that's what it feels like just so you
know oh
wow oh my
God this traveled across the
world so here's why his work speaks so
much to me so first of all he's
combining so many different
references it's Nike the goddess of
Victory right it's that looks like an
angel as well um the Italian futurists
which is my favorite art movement from
the early 20th century they tried to
capture Motion in 2D or 3D form well
Jake thank
you thank you thank you thank you for
creating beautiful things thank you for
caring about somebody like me and
somebody like Michael who really feel
the love that's the other thing when you
have something that matters to you in
your house and you're having a bad day
you can look at it and remember you know
what I mean that Spirit of joy and I
actually have a list here okay I got a
little rant ready you want to hear my
rant yeah let's go one of the things
that drives me
crazy is when people especially
conservatives think that all
Contemporary Art is ugly or abstract or
like literally garbage M and there's a
lot of that but so much of the stuff out
there in galleries is not only not a
crazy expensive but they're trying to
sell things for people in their house
and these are young artists you know
they're trying to add Beauty I have a
list so if you don't believe me and you
think all Contemporary Art is garbage or
terrible go to the website or any of
these places that I'm going to Rattle
off look through them and you're telling
me that that it's not about creating
Beauty and joy and things in people's
Liv so I don't have any relationship
with any of these people these are just
some galleries I follow on Instagram
utre Gallery antler Gallery giant robot
2 binart I don't know how to pronounce
I'm sorry b a b i n a r t spoke Art
Gallery VAR Gallery in Milwaukee I was
there the pieces were not expensive at
all what kind of art are we talking
about everything mostly paintings mostly
paintings some sculptures too like this
Cory hord is my favorite one in La
Knight Gallery vertical Gallery Avant
Gallery Hive Gallery Haven gallery and
curio Art Gallery I'm telling you you uh
it's not exorbitant this is not the kind
of thing where you have to go to Museum
and be like this doesn't make sense to
me you look at it right away you're like
okay I know what this is and it's
beautiful it's awesome um and you're
supporting someone who's young and
creative trying to do something and make
the world a better place so I'm a big
fan of the Contemporary Art scene a lot
of it is not great but even the stuff
that's not great is very rarely
disgusting or gross it's just like okay
I've seen this before or something like
that okay there's it's like differ
between there's like a standup where
like I'll pay money for the ticket and
someone's like who's an opener it's like
I wouldn't pay to see him perform but he
sure still made me laugh that person is
still more by far more good than bad so
a lot of this artist and stuff I would
own but it's like okay I get it I like
it